here's some bad stuff going on in
China They're bringing back the masks
and they're bringing back social
distancing this according to a report
from the Sun out of the UK China has
brought back masks social distancing in
a chilling echo of lockdown as they
battle a mystery pneumonia outbreak four
years on from covid alarming footage has
emerged of mask wearing crowds inside
Chinese hospitals as fears of a new
pandemic sweep across the globe okay
before I totally lose it
before I melt down in a Cascade of fear
and
trembling we can
remember Asian people have been wearing
masks in public for a very long
time Asian people have been wearing
masks on airplanes and even on public
streets for a long time that was always
an Asian thing and then during covid for
the first time it started to spill over
into the west and we mostly got rid of
it so the fact that some people in China
are wearing masks doesn't worry me all
too much what worries me about this
story is the
number say four years on from covid four
years on from Co what happens every four
years what do you think might
explain the political reaction to covid
four years ago was it just that for the
first time ever everyone melted down out
of a panic over a cold we just happen to
really be afraid of that cold over other
colds or do you think it might have had
that reaction might have had something
to do with the presidential election and
the prospect of another Donald Trump
term and do we think that maybe the
fearmongers now who don't seem to be
winning are freaking out over the
potential of another
virus because the exact same Prospect
faces them who was the biggest
beneficiary of
covid we could say the libs we could say
me mega corporations it was the biggest
transfer of wealth ever from the lower
ler classes to the upper classes in in
all of recorded
history I think the biggest beneficiary
of Co was China
China because covid shut down the United
States it politically neutered Donald
Trump after many other other attempts
that's the one that that
succeeded Trump was winning waging and
winning a trade war with China Co
stopped the trade war with
China Co got rid of Donald Trump because
it gave Democrats an excuse to change
all of the election rules to benefit
them
uh and what are we looking at now we're
looking at despite all of that Donald
Trump looking as though he can beat Joe
Biden Donald Trump up not just in
National polls which don't tell a lot of
the story but up in crucial states that
he's got to win if you look at the real
clear politics average of polls so we're
not talking about allers we're talking
about the most
Dependable source for polling
Trump is up almost five points in
Arizona Trump is up four or five points
in Georgia on Joe Biden Trump is this is
not a generic ballot this is not fill in
the blank who knows what's going to
happen Donald Trump is look according to
the polls and not just one or two all of
the polls and not just now for for a
very long time now Trump is looking like
he could win again so the libs are
freaking out they're going to try to
pull some virus out from under the rug
they're going to try to find some excuse
to to cement their cheating in in the
new voting rules but it's looking pretty
strong right now go to Ru greens.com slm
the holidays are here while you're out
shopping for your family and friends do
not forget to shop for your pets too
give your dog the gift of a healthier
and happier life with rough greens
naturopathic doctor Dennis black the
founder of Ru greens is focused on
improving the health of every dog in
America dog food might as well be
considered dead food since it contains
very little nutritional value let rough
greens bring your excuse me rough greens
bring your dogs food to life rough
greens is a supplement that contains all
the necessary vitamins minerals
probiotics Omega oils digestive enzymes
and don't forget antioxidants that your
dog needs you don't even have to go out
and get new dog food you just sprinkle
rough Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving raving
about rough greens it supports healthy
joints improves bad breath boosts energy
levels and much more you are what you
eat right now naturopathic Dr Dennis
black is so confident that this will
improve your dog's health he's offering
a free jump start trial bag so your dog
can try it delivered straight to your
door in just a few days go to Ruff
greens.com Michel m h a l or call 844
ruff1 123 that is rfffg greens.com m i c
h a l or call 844 Ruff
rf123 today Zoom fatigue is taking its
toll on your health this is according to
a report published in the journal
scientific
reports looked for physiological signs
of fatigue in 35 students attending
lectures on engineering at an Austrian
University uh they found that there were
notable differences between the
in-person and the online groups so since
covid a lot of people have had to and
even chosen to do their meetings and
even have social Gatherings on Zoom
zoom and the survey the study found that
video participants fatigue mounted over
the course of the session their brain
states showed that they were struggling
to pay attention the group's moods
varied as well in-person participants
reported feeling livelier happier and
more active online participants said
they felt tired drowsy and fed up of
course I hate Zoom sometimes people want
to schedule Zoom meetings with me I try
to avoid it I'll I'll have it on the
phone if I'm going to do an in not iners
meeting but I want to do stuff in person
and the reason is it doesn't take a
scientific study to know that human
beings prefer to do things in person
than virtually and the reason for this
is that same religious error that Jeremy
was pointing out that we were discussing
earlier namely we are incarnate beings
we are Body and Soul we are not to be
abstracted one from the other we're both
tied together this is I think one of the
drivers of
the beyond the uh bizarre philosophy The
Logical conclusion of liberalism beyond
the I don't know whatever chemicals
they're putting in the water a a Big
Driver of it is technology the fact that
we live in the virtual world so often
now makes us think that our bodies don't
really matter that we are something
totally different from our bodies and if
you really believe that then you can say
all right well I don't like my body I I
I feel alienated from my body so I'm
going to pretend that my identity has
nothing to do with my body and I might
even chop my body up to to make it look
a little bit more like my fantasy view
of of who I supposedly really am but at
a at a more quotidian level this is
happening to people all the time as they
undertake their stupid Zoom
meetings you're that's not going to
satisfy you to just sit in front of a
screen all day and look at little moving
pixels you're a human being you're
supposed to move around and talk to real
human beings and touch them and even
during goodness gracious during Co when
we we weren't allowed to see our loved
ones you had to hug people up against a
plate of glass or something no we need
to hug each other we need to we need
to have human contact we're a coupling
creature a social animal the political
animal
okay the liberal culture wants to
replace marriage with well a new fake
definition of marriage and ultimately
just replace it with porn you know just
replace it with with uh sitting alone in
in your in your home looking at pixels
wants to replace office settings work
settings where you see people and
interact and have lunch wants to replace
that
with sitting in your home looking at
moving pixels it wants to replace
everything with this abstracted view
wants to replace your community of
friends with virtual online friends all
the rest of it it's not going to work
that will never work we are incarnate
beings boy what a great clip that was
now hey hey hey hey hold up hey did you
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
NS YouTube channel we'll see you next
time